well joining me now is the talk TV
presenter and former culture secretary
Nadine Doris a former BBC News night
political editor Michael Crick I'm the
chairman of founder of intertalent
Rights group Jonathan Chalet so welcome
to all of you Michael Crick let me start
with you as a BBC man for so many years
what do you make of this obviously we
don't as things stand really know
exactly what has happened his claim and
counterclaim but we do know that a very
uh senior BBC presenter has been
suspended by the corporation and we do
know that apparently the first
allegations were made to the BBC about
his conduct back in May so what did we
make of this well I think tonight it
looks uh rather less serious for the BBC
than it did say 12 hours ago first of
all we've had the Metropolitan Police
today saying at this stage they're not
investigating which rather suggests that
they don't think the evidence that
they're aware of so far is strong enough
that they're much more important is this
uh statement by the lawyers for this
young man that uh the the sun story is a
load of rubbish
um and that he actually contacted the
sun to tell them that on Friday well I
mean you're a former tabloid editor what
was the editor of the Sun what was the
Sun newspaper doing going ahead and
defaming an unnamed member of the BBC
staff on the basis of an experience by a
young man that the young man denied I
mean it seems to me that all of this
attack all of your monologue just now is
all about attacking the BBC I think the
Sun newspaper the Murdoch Empire has a
lot to answer tonight and frankly one
has to wonder whether the articles that
the sun has been running over the last
few days are all part of that ongoing
war between uh Mr Murdoch and his
newspapers and the British Broadcasting
Corporation
I mean I think the the sun has been
pretty robust in this response it was a
pathetic approach tonight that that was
what happened just to be clear I'm not
I'm not involved in the inner workings
of the sun on this I have no inside
knowledge I realize that but there's
evidence they had all I've seen their
statement
the mother of the alleged victim has
clearly been talking uh freely to the
sun apparently for no payment about all
this so clearly the truth is going to
want is going to emerge and like I say
we don't actually know as things stand
where that truth lies and the son of
course took a decision not to name the
presenter let me bring in Nadine Doris I
mean Nadine uh Michael quick raises some
interesting questions there but again
we're all slightly guessing aren't we
about what has really happened here but
is it is it right as many believe that
the BBC in the way they've handled this
once again seem to be lacking
so yeah again it seems like it doesn't
matter what crisis threatens to engulf
the BBC and there have been many over a
number of years they seem completely
unable to be on the front foot and to
have a a robust set of processes in
place to deal with complaints as they
happen past the BBC problem is that they
just don't seem to be able to deal with
issues as they arrive and one would have
thought the experience they've had
whether it's been with Frank bath or
Gary lineker or whether it's
um Jimmy Savile or whoever whichever
situation arises you'd think that by now
they've got enough experience with
dealing with the potential crisis to
know what to do how to do it how to how
to protect their own brand which is the
BBC and also how to make sure that they
deal with the complaints effectively
because you know at the back of all of
these complaints there are always real
lives and real people people and real
victims and that's part of the tragedy
if they could just get on the front foot
and deal with things quickly and
effectively then a lot of hurt would be
saved all around and I think that's
that's part of the problem it's an
inefficiency and uh an inability to deal
with what are very serious problems you
know you're quite right in your opening
comments the BBC is paid for by the
British public by license fee payers and
that's not a cheap cost to people who
are struggling with cost of living at
the moment you know the BBC has a
responsibility to the people that it
serves and sometimes it just asks as
apps as though the only people the BBC
have to satisfy are the BBC is the BBC
itself and it isn't it should be
accountable it should be transparent and
it has to answer to the public and
that's sometimes what it forgets and
what it always fails to do
Jonathan Charlotte there are lots of
reputations at stake here the BBC the
presenter concerned obviously the the
young alleged victim that victim's
family so many people uh indeed the the
media themselves of course as Michael
Crick said
um
what about the issue of social media
what about the way that so many
completely unconnected BBC presenters
have been dragged through the mud you
know I saw Nikki Campbell talking about
how distressing he found it Jeremy Vine
how distressing he found it uh Gary
lineker having to clarify it wasn't him
Rylan Clark and so on I mean it's been
appalling to watch but it reminds me
again that you know the the mainstream
media have a lot of restrictions on them
a lot of restrictions now some of the
most Draconian actually in in the Free
World but social media Remains the wild
west what do we do about this well the D
Ventures culture sector tries to do a
lot about that it's horrific what's
going on on social media not just this
matter continually so terrible things
are happening on social media and people
are being named I mean the reason most
people in Britain know the individual
presenter is it's because he's been
named on social media and to add to that
their pictures which are going around
social media whether they're real
pictures or AI pictures I don't know but
the picture looks a pretty unpleasant
picture the problem with social media is
you rightly said peers whether it be
talk TV the BBC ITV Channel 4 they're
very carefully governed but social media
is out of control and the government
until now in spite of all their efforts
have been unable to control social media
Michael Craig the presenter concerned we
all know who it is the public don't know
who it is yet would it be prudent for
this presenter to Simply come out if he
has nothing to hide if what this uh
young alleged victim has put in this
legal letter is true and there's nothing
illegal or improper about whatever
relationship they may or may not have
had would it not be uh the smart thing
to do for this presenter to come out and
talk frankly about this and and maybe
not even defend himself but just say
this is what happened and I have nothing
to hide I think uh that might it it
might well make sense for them to do
that indeed I think uh managers in the
BBC if there's some frustration there
that this presenter hasn't done that yet
and that they uh daily wish that they
would do so because I think at some
point they're going to have to come out
and make a statement about what did and
what didn't happen
um and I suspect it's it's uh somewhere
between uh I didn't do anything wrong
and uh the allegations that the the sun
has made
um but I I I don't think that they can
remain in hiding for uh forever they're
going to have to say something before
long and they might as well do it now
rather than wait a another few days or
maybe a few more weeks nice step in yes
and say all three of you have attacked
the BBC in different ways I think as has
happened today with this letter from a
top law firm is called harbottle and
Lewis I understand as you as you said
the law firm connected with the queen
they've sent a very firm letter saying
that the alleged victim is saying what
his parents have said weren't wasn't
true on that basis the BBC have been
wise to hold to hold back and not say
too much because the facts clearly
aren't known and I think it's wrong to
expect the BBC to jump in and give a
conclusion to this until they know I
also suspect they're presenter in
question has probably been told by the
BBC to say nothing I would put money on
that so I think there are no options but
to wait and also remember all weekend
there's massive allegations of 17 he was
17 when we started well the police have
jumped in today and they've made it
clear they're not rushing this so we
don't even know if the police agree it
was a 17 year old at the time so I think
quite simply as much as the public would
like to know more and as much as
everyone's pushing for the public to
know more the BBC has to be responsible
to also the alleged victim the presenter
the presenter's family it's not simple
to say name and chain someone
immediately without all the facts being
known that's not to say or condone what
didn't happen but I think caution is the
right thing until all the facts no I
don't I don't disagree with that but
it's been it's been an awful mess the
way that other presenters have been
Dragged In from this uh and of course we
don't know what evidence the sun has
they've been pretty cautious so far in
what they've published they haven't
revealed the name of the people of the
person they're talking about they
haven't revealed much information at all
about that so I think we have to wait
and see what the sun has it been as I
said robust in their statement in
response to this legal letter and we'll
see where this all takes us uh Nadine
actually I don't think peers that they
have been robust in response to this
legal letter they've what they've done
is they've gone back on the attack
against the BBC they haven't actually
specifically answered the question that
the points made in this legal letter
which are that this young man has denied
uh the the story uh
as total rubbish
um and also they haven't answered the
point made in the legal letter that the
young man contacted the son on Friday to
tell them that it was is rubbish what's
the son's response to that I think
actually it's a very weak response from
the Sun tonight what we're going to I
think we're going to find out I suspect
from the Sun exactly what they have
which is behind their decision to
publish in the first place and we'll see
what that is but you make perfectly
valid points and Nadine you've had to
deal at the sharp end in government of
what to do about social media uh what do
you make of what's happened in the last
few days with so many completely
innocent people getting their
reputations completely trashed
and I've spoken to one of those people
myself actually
um yeah it's it's incredibly difficult
it is the social media is like the wild
west and with the Online safety bill
which is being debated in the Lords at
the moment hopefully some of the
Amendments the Lords will put down to
what has been a watered-down bill since
the new admination Administration took
over will have some really robust
measures in to deal with some of this
but it's um it's always going to be that
balance between you know freedom of
speech the fact that we now have social
media something which is still a
relatively new and recent territory with
the new emerging platforms which are
constantly
um constantly coming up so it's always
going to be a battle and we're always
going to play catch up whatever the
Online safety Bill puts into law and
which hopefully will receive royalists
very uh later this year will finish its
January Parliament by the summer once
that bill becomes law there were
Provisions in it which means that the
bill can continually not have to pay
catch up and will continually be able to
amend I'm not sure if those Powers will
still stand by the time we reach the
Autumn I hope they do because if they
don't we'll be in a position where a
bill becomes law in the Autumn which
will already be out of date by the time
that happens because there's platforms
AI all the problems that we're facing at
the moment as a result of internet usage
is moves so fast that it's very
difficult for governments to keep up
the dean Doris thank you very much
Michael Crick thank you very much
Jonathan Charlotte thank you very much
and we're told there are more
Revelations coming in the Sun newspaper
tonight so we will see what they have to
say and the story I'm sure was a long
way to go